[Music]
Montclair New Jersey an affluent
suburban community just 20 minutes from
Manhattan in the heart of town sits in
Italian Eatery called Leones opened more
than a decade ago by Rose Leone well my
mom first off in Leone's in 1996.
Leone's was the place to go to if you
wanted Italian food welcome to Leone's
do you have a reservation
be blind
here 8 o'clock in the morning till 12 at
night I did everything cooking cleaning
the inventory Mama treated this
restaurant like her child this
restaurant was her life
about two years ago my mother went in
for a routine kidney stone the operation
went bad and she went into a coma which
was very very difficult
and brothers he was Ill it was a bad
moment you look around you don't see
Rosie
there's nothing here and that's what
hurts
[Music]
without Mama Rose everybody was just
scrambling to make it work literally she
said the fish was drying she didn't like
the polenta was soft is that the polenta
Michael stepped in and he says he's the
boss but doesn't do anything boss worthy
he shows up around six marks around
hands out of sambuca as long as you're
21 it's my tree watch this little
football
against dinner
okay okay that goes home all right see
you later Michael's not taking care of
this restaurant so basically I do
everything I do ordering I coordinate
staff you're supposed to make a menu the
way the menu stays my goal does not show
any concern about this restaurant and
when everybody sees that they do the
same the kids who's there they take naps
out in the back they play soccer
hello after Michael took over the food
went to [ __ ] there's no flavor the taste
just wasn't there anymore I mean this
place used to be good I'm not happy
anymore business nowadays is awful we
are very slow last weekend we had 12 to
15 tables on a Friday night and that's
that new reservations without losing
There's No Reservations
[Music]
two years later when I come back I
almost had a heart attack Everything I
seen was dirty so if this is filthy I'm
afraid about what the kitchen looks like
kitchen out of control that's just crazy
disgusting what are you doing they
destroyed everything I worked for in my
life there was no Management in the
restaurant
interference to nothing
we owe 1400 for the meat overdue for the
past month I eat my goal to make the
money
but you can live my boat I don't know
how can I ask you
something Michael you tell me what do
you want me to do let me check Ramsay to
come in and straighten them out Chef
Ramsey it seems to be my
if it doesn't work out
I will have no other choice but to die
foreign
[Music]
games and trying to deal with customers
at the same time yes it is Chef really
yes not bad yes sir wow yeah go outside
yes sir and come back in in 10 seconds
okay
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
hello table for one sir yeah I'm busy
okay two seconds I'm just gonna watch
this girl would you mind I'll see myself
um busy I'm just trying to find the game
it's so important because this is far
more important than running my business
seriously honestly Michael did you get
the message I mean it just
a good Impressions the customer's
walking in for the first time
no terrible Chef Ramsay looked at me in
such a way like what is this rodent
doing next to a television in a
restaurant it was just embarrassing oh
my God is that a baby yes I mean they
say that there's never an ugly baby I
think I just found one but that's not
you is it no sir we have one of the
worst of course I've ever seen the
creepy baby keeps me up at night I don't
know what I'm not always thinking about
this everything you see every artwork
was my mother rice my mother's actually
the owner and I was kind of like the
general manager until she got sick oh
everything she got sick yes my mom's
name is Rose okay is your mother here
yes okay can we meet please please
[Music]
[Music]
I've been married three times I need
number four are you feeling better
okay and how long have you been back in
the business
so if you just come back now how long
were you out for
eign
wow I'm sorry um how long do you have
the restaurants 14
in your mind what's wrong with the
restaurants what is it
everything
okay let's get the group together and
let's have a little meeting and a catch
up and I'd like to hear from everybody
so I can get my head around this okay
yeah can we get the chefs and uh yeah
everybody please Michael yes
so this is John John good to see you
thank you this is Elizabeth Elizabeth
nice to see you and you are I'm truly
truly right it's a lovely night and
what'd you do I'm a waitress a waitress
I'm sorry John what'd you do I'm a
waiter waiter Elizabeth Hostess Hostess
because I've met the man that was in
charge of the TV control
Chef Ramsay is going to tear Michael a
new [ __ ] I would hope that Michael
knows that he has a coming but it is my
goal so he probably doesn't know that he
has it coming okay good
um first of all I can't start to even
think about turning this place around
until I get to the bottom of the issues
um who'd like to go first
wow Trudy the major problem here is
there is no manager there are no nobody
in control this restaurant basically the
staff is running this restaurant right
now I I disagree I believe the problem
is is that I believe the decor is a turn
off the deck no this is ridiculous she
got sick I had to step up to the plate I
take care of payroll I take care of
ordering and take care of old payables
receiving doing the menus wow is that
right
what would happen if Trudy fell ill God
forbid
where in the hell would we be I don't
know the answer that actually if I don't
know do you want it
you don't do you yes I do are you
incapable I think I am capable so why
have you done it when I see the business
not busy it's hard for me they're really
short passion have you ever had the
passion yes
I don't think he ever had the past he's
never had it
wow is that true I don't think so chef
I fell into it hoping that Michael
somewhere along the lines would learn
from me but he hasn't made the
initiative my foreign
I think the bottom line shift is
everyone can do more
I think the servers can do more I think
the Busboys can do more and the chefs
can do more are you here every day
except Monday yeah I'm here every day
except Monday so you're here six days a
week across those six days a week you're
in here you're here what 12 14 hours a
day no no how many I work the dinner
shift from like uh five to ten five to
eleven so five hours a day out of those
five hours a night how many of them do
you sit down
depending on the situation roughly two
three so you're on your feet for two
hours a day yes holy crap
what's the break even per week in this
restaurant
[Music]
twelve thousand dollars what we're
taking currently a week eight thousand
we're losing four grand a week yes sir
we're drown
around the business doesn't cover the
expense there is zombies if you can't
live wow okay I'm gonna have a look
around I'm gonna be back in 20 minutes
okay so do me a favor just make me one
of everything on that menu
our menu is 15 pages let's go and I just
left because I knew it was going to look
like a freaking Chinese buffet I need
one of every password okay on the menu
we need chicken parm Jill Palms shrimp
parm eggplant parm all the Farms
literally one of every pizza please
don't forget the sides I think the
pizza's top top notch and I think most
of the food is outstanding I can hear
six days a week don't forget your pizza
special too there you go I appreciate it
small place more plates more plates
in the window
[Music]
okay surprise
oh my gosh holy crap look all this food
bloody hell I need to get up to speed so
I'm gonna keep it simple just make me
one of everything after a meeting with
the staff Chef Ramsay is anxious to get
up to speed on the food I need one of
every pasta all pumps but when he
returns he makes a shocking Discovery
yes holy crap a dining room full of food
how many items on the menu over a
hundred a hundred
foreign
physically their parents Jesus Christ
can I have a night before please maybe a
bag a [ __ ] sick bag Chef Ramsay I
would like to apologize in advance it's
just everything's just
where'd you start here what's what this
is sweet onion pie
this is a basic Basics pie
crust looks very dark is that normal
there or is he just having an off day
the oven gets very hard so
have you tasted that
how bland is that
I think the texture I don't like the
taste you like the taste but you don't
like the texture yeah
is that Rice
that's risotto
risotto
come on guys I mean [ __ ] do me a
favor
now is that you no sir what
don't think so
just smell that
still inside
I don't want you smelling that no no not
with your state of health I don't want
you back in a coma Taste of them
quick
ah mine's full of grit little spongy
spongy most great they're not even clean
yeah are you crunching grits yes yes
dirt Sands how do you clean a clam if
it's steel you run them under [ __ ]
cold water oh I don't even know yeah
Lord only knows where those clams came
from at least it was just sand that's
all I'm saying what is that that's our
ribiata why is all the vinegar on there
people like that recipe they love it
actually
oh my God the chilies
the garlic I mean that is a [ __ ]
disaster next row what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] is it it's chicken and
balsamic sauce yeah
[Music]
they should come with a [ __ ] watering
that will blow your lungs out I mean
and whereabouts in Italy is that from
oh come on
there's no seasoning in there
everything's blast Bland fish
it's like a [ __ ] flip-flop look at
the garlic in there too much garlic
fishing we're going way too much garlic
how many bulbs of Garlic's in there a
lot of garlic yeah are they trying to
put me in hospital for two years
I mean it's bad it is bad I mean
honestly give me the chefs out here will
you please my photo even though I think
it needs help it's definitely not that
bad by eating myself it's not as bad as
the chef's head who made this
I did it
have you tasted it
have you ever sat down and tasted your
own food sit down without us no no with
what would happen sit down come on
quickly I need you to taste it I know
sit down please yes welcome to leonias
there we are
I know it is this
[Music]
how does that taste can I have a fork no
you're not eating that no no I'm not
gonna be responsible putting you back in
Hospital Sit down you are not eating
that how does that taste
how does it taste I don't like for
something I don't like you don't like it
I don't know how was that
it's very vinegary have you tasted your
risotto yes I do taste your result but
yeah stay there you have a little taste
yeah just have a taste that episode use
your knife before have a little taste
how does that taste
wow
it's [ __ ] disgusting and if that's
classed as a risotto here in New Jersey
dude you've got to get out more
what if any dish do you like on these
tables
nothing at all
[Music]
when a chef doesn't like his own food
how the [ __ ] do you expect the customer
to for me that says it all even your
chefs don't like their food I think it's
good you think it's good well
are you in denial or are you just doing
this
let me get some fresh air I'll be back
later yeah
I'd like to catch a plane out here right
now
[Music]
looks after discovering early on that
Leone's menu is more about quantity than
quality Chef Ramsay returns to observe
dinner service and news of his arrival
in Montclair has spread and the
restaurant is busy for the first time in
years
okay hi how are you good how are you and
this is my wife Cheyenne Cheyenne oh
you're Michael's wife yes well didn't he
do well yeah good right um tonight run
the place as normal I'd like to see how
this thing functions I've tasted it yeah
now I want to see how it works take me
to the kitchen show me the line please
here's our um fire area salad and
desserts
Diana okay great and how long we've been
here I've been here seven years seven
years yes wow okay great
um the main problem with the rest of his
what
so the main problem is the food the food
wow I like the honesty I work here and I
try to take pride in my work but I don't
think the food is good Michael needs the
eye opener
pick it out take it out
[Music]
while diners try to digest their food
Gordon is having a hard time digesting
what he sees in the kitchen what the
[ __ ] is that in there is that how he
hates it
we blast it in the microwave
it's very Italian
and here what's in here
[Music]
I do yesterday this chicken you do this
yesterday
so hold on a minute that's cooked
chicken and what's that in there here
later today so you have the raw Veil
next to the cooked chicken come on the
cooks are to blame for their part if
they make a mistake I could live with
that but something about it being
irresponsible and neglectful there's no
excuse look at that crap in here bloody
Hells Bells what's that in there
is that calamari yeah it comes in
definitely fresh though that I know
perfect fresh it's frozen you buy this
in fresh it is not fresh we use it here
is all Frozen
oh Jesus what is that in there
what is that I think it's feel shot you
think it's veal pretty sure you didn't
put it in there no I didn't that or what
is up that looks like meat thrown in a
pan but what is it though I don't know
it's not labeled oh my God
forget the orders for five minutes and
come around you Daryl come round
don't worry about the cooking for now
I've got more [ __ ] issues where's the
last time this was organized hasn't been
organized oh come on what's that alas
molasses I've been in there since
Thanksgiving what it's July what's that
oh my god
oh [ __ ] this is raw pork
that's not my fault that you serve to me
is it no that's uh of the old poker they
left that there are that's the old pork
where's this one from not Thanksgiving
again stuff what mushroom smell that
smell it that's [ __ ] older than me
smell it yawn that's your sauce Daryl
what in the [ __ ] is this oh my God
is that flounder exactly almost
definitely old it's green
smell that
it was embarrassing it was mortifying he
comes in something that's so easily
identifiable and no one noticed smell it
how is that possible oh
because you're sharing something for two
seconds Mama Rose I am absolutely
horrified that's from Thanksgiving
and that's a slimy
vile sticky flounder
a sour disgusting cream sauce I mean
honestly this restaurant has been run
like a pigsty you may be resistant to
change but what's become very clear is
that your resistance
to Quality
[Music]
dishwashers
have it done it should have been done
always all of you come here
let's go come here how can we work like
that
got ingredients from last Thanksgiving
did you smell the flounder yes did you
see the cooked chicken the raw pork the
raw veal it's a joke you should be
ashamed of yourselves under no
circumstances can we continue to serve
food shut the place down
after discovering disgusting and
dangerous practices in Leone's kitchen
under no circumstances can we continue
to serve food Chef Ramsay has no choice
but to shut the place down
you're in the dining room now and just
apologize
get [ __ ] cleaning get it going okay
tell him no more service for the rest of
the night or just till they're done
cleaning
what do you think not at all
just embarrassed us I'm [ __ ]
embarrassed
[Music]
everybody
I'm sorry to interrupt you everybody I'm
sad to say and embarrassed to say that
for closing down Leone's for the night
the food is not up to par it's not what
you deserve so I apologize for your
inconvenience I thank you for choosing
Leone's but right now it's a must we
must shut down
you shut it down that's it you shut it
down sorry guys
the Orange is never even shut down very
relaxed by it won't sleep until that
over this
thank you ma'am sorry take care sorry
about that ladies
I'm feeling disappointment I'm feeling
itilated telling everyone that they
can't eat at my own restaurant
can you sit down please
that's the most badly practiced kitchen
I've ever seen
that's why we need yourself no Michael
no Michael
you let it happen on a daily basis you
need to run your business
you don't understand
you don't understand
hi Kesha no in your mother's eyes you
don't have you ever walked into your
kitchen and opened the door to your
Refrigeration units and call them out
and I checked but I don't check hard
enough obviously what are you talking
about oh my stopping man stop it you're
oblivious it's happening under your own
nose
I don't give a [ __ ]
because you don't
Diana is he lazy yes John is he lazy yes
sir Trudy is he lazy yes Mama he is
right now we have a room full of
individuals that don't believe
in your conviction to run this place
prove to me
and more importantly to your mother and
your staff that you are ready to lead
got it got it
[Music]
a manager who doesn't manage my God
foreign
[Music]
I don't feel like I've given up but I
feel like I'm broken I'm angry at myself
I think as the boss of the restaurant it
was just irresponsible
[Music]
well taking
take each restaurant for myself
I don't know I think seeing is believing
are you okay Ma yeah somebody crying
come here what's in my head
what's the matter oh what's the matter
we're gonna turn the ship around
[Music]
my mother put in all
my money I'm crushed that I might let
her down and I want to make it good but
the truth is I don't know if I can turn
it around and it's a scary feeling it
really is
come on get out of there get some rest
okay
okay
after shutting down Leone's Chef Ramsay
realizes Michael and his staff need to
have their eyes opened and he's arranged
something appropriate at an art gallery
only half a block away take a look at
this amazing exhibition come in
look at that
what'd you see food what kind of food
you see on there what Italian food
that's very pleasurable to the eye is it
inviting yes yes this is your
competition
only blocks away from leonis
[Music]
Michael I went to five restaurants this
morning
lovely thank you I took the pictures and
trust me after shooting those dishes
I ate everything and they don't only
look great wow that was delicious but
they taste amazing
I was glad that Michael got to see what
else was in the neighborhood instead of
living in the denial that our food is
fantastic your dishes set an impression
and they remain in people's memories
so
let's take a look at these dishes from
another local restaurant
this restaurant's called that's right
Leone is do you recognize the food yes
wow
I've never seen such an outdated mess in
all my life take a look at that and then
turn around
and have a look at your competition
come on Trudy what's the message I'm
trying to get across get your [ __ ]
together your food is no comparison to
what's in the neighborhood I can't
believe it but I'm embarrassed to serve
food like that shuts up in my eyes to
the neighboring competition and I think
it takes someone outside the family and
your friends to tell you how it is today
we move in this direction
let's get back to Leones and get started
let's go I think it's time for a change
you're not going to be the best Italian
restaurant in town
with Michael finally realizing how much
his restaurant has slipped Gordon's next
move is to push Michael to better
understand his business when was the
last time you cooked anything never and
that means working in the kitchen I want
you get to watch me now cook a delicious
veal chop and a simple capellini but I
wanted to do them with me you don't need
to be an amazing Chef to understand when
your chefs are going badly wrong use
your hearts continue being blindsided by
your Brigade and need you to start
leading from the helm you start running
your business
okay you know field chop let's go to be
the man of the house I have to take all
the responsibility I mean I have to take
a kick in the ass a lot of people depend
on me if you follow me every step of the
way Church of olive oil now yeah salt
and pepper it's cooked on the bone why
are we cooking on the bone more flavor
right get that pan nice and hot how do
you know when the oil is ready I like
smoking off there you've got the sear in
there wow leave that searing away it's
never crossed your mind to come in and
cook from time to time sort of no it's
one of those things as the Italian
Prince my mother always did the cooking
it even adds from my mind it is very
embarrassing I don't know how different
positions in my restaurant I think it's
time for change the most important thing
is to see you know I'll leave my pride
aside I want to do better
we go
convection seven minutes okay completely
in gently now gently push and pull back
nice there we go good let's go check our
bill
is that ready Chef I want you to tell me
for once I want to pull it right now
let's go then pull it cooking what Chef
Ramsay has given me great confidence in
myself and in my restaurant I'm sure I
will make some errors but I have to
learn it has to come the hard way look
at that visually how do they look they
look fantastic do they belong in the
gallery or the garbage the gallery okay
dig in guys please dig in dig in dig in
it just melts in your mouth
I love the fact that someone above
Michael they had the knowledge she
finally pushed him it was very good for
Michael delicious John what do you think
of the film the bill was excellent yeah
it's probably the best food that's ever
come out of that kitchen
the staff when they seen the food they
look at me in a different light knowing
that I couldn't do the job and it wasn't
just a bump on a log that could sit in
the front I don't think I've seen Trudy
eat or smile in about two years
I don't blame it you may recognize him
from sat on his ass outside watching
television
but that guy's gone now you have a new
Michael let's go
after feeling a little more positive
about Michael Chef Ramsay's Team Works
through the night to transform Leone's
from a sleepy and dated restaurant into
a modern Italian Bistro
[Music]
good morning good morning chef today we
are relaunching the new leonis are you
ready I'm ready let's go come in come in
please come in WoW
excellent
this is the same room wow
wow
big deep breath God is the dated salmon
color now we have something sort of
contemporary we have some Elegance for
the tablecloths red and white chairs the
new lampshades cool contemporary
fabulous God the walls laced with
Hideous artwork we use the phrase to put
an imprints of Italy very nice as soon
as I opened the door it was like a whole
different world it's amazing beautiful
surrounding that makes you feel like
you're in Italy I love that campaign to
Decor in this restaurant no more
of it I have another big surprise this
is going to make your life so much
easier I have for you the most amazing
state of the art point of sale system
provided by Zephyr hardware and POS Lavo
it is the state of the Arts latest touch
screen device each and every dish has
been photographed and programmed on
there you go to the table you take
the order from wireless touch screen
device
you've left the table the order is in
the kitchen I might have to cry oh my
god I've been asking them to get any
kind of computer here for years this
handwritten stuff has to go and thank
God it's finally gone we're like a real
restaurant you are like a real
restaurant before Gordon Ramsay came
here this was an outdated New Jersey
restaurant after Gordon Ramsay this
restaurant fits right in it's just this
modern classic Italian Bistro
Taste Of Happiness oh mama Rose
[Music]
come on in addition to revamping Leone's
Decor Chef Ramsay has overhauled their
massive and stale menu and replaced it
with fresh and Innovative modern Italian
dishes these dishes are good enough to
go in any Gallery when I seen the food I
really was excited the most eye-popping
dishes I've seen in a long time
it's exactly the first way I felt when I
saw you
let's start off on the top heirloom
tomatoes which with cucumber and a
cherry vinaigrette then
[Music]
then yeah fresh crab beautiful I love it
when you think of Italian Classics you
think of a chicken cacciatore polenta
olives mushrooms and tomatoes vibrant
fresh it's beautiful a delicious shrimp
scampi a roasted pan seared Cod
marinator a menu one third of the size
with 45 dishes that can change
frequently got it yeah wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
everything on the menu was out of this
world this food is a complete 180 from
what we were serving here before I'm
very happy right now
I absolutely love all the dishes on this
venue and you just could taste the
difference of the freshness as soon as
it goes in your mouth we're back back in
business
[Music]
it's relaunch night at Leone's and after
an overhaul of a menu and the decor Chef
Ramsay is encouraged by Michael's new
attitude and so he expects them to take
complete control of his restaurant
tonight we're gonna get it done and when
you expedite I want you holding the fort
together sure yeah King of the castle
Yeah we're getting the weeds we get out
we stay good together as a team oh my
God yeah I'm nervous I'm excited I got
the butterflies but I think it's time
for me to make this business run the way
it should I know what I can do it
tonight
we're gonna get it done let's go come on
move let's go
hi welcome to the new Leones
Leone's once a famed restaurant in this
community had lost its way this is our
menu tonight with news of the relaunch
diners are streaming in ready to give it
another chance are we ready to order
okay what would you like okay Pizza
let's go Pizza I'm so impressed by this
I adore the PLS just it was really cool
I mean the ease of ordering it was
incredible and my handwriting is
atrocious so this for me is a dream come
true
[Music]
appetizers one soup one dollar mod thank
you come here buddy this one is that's
our new food around here okay good how
are your first name is Alex good to see
you so what's going next we're looking
at Table Six okay let's go Michael is
off to a good start
ensuring quality dish after dish is
quickly leaving the kitchen this looks
awesome and diners are thrilled with the
new menu
how does everything look very good okay
and everyone's loving it I mean loving
it
kitchen has hit a roadblock Alex this
right here is Table Three as Michael in
an attempt to push food out fast has
lost control
and ascending an order out to a table
that has already received its food
all right
oh come on we're not getting anywhere
guys we've already sent the appetizers
just shake that was at six
then check six
it's not the same table now just
checking if yeah
we're sending food out twice oh for
[ __ ] sake come on
Michael table six and three are eating
do you know what you're doing
Mike
screw it up boy Michael needs to step up
to the plate I know it everyone knows
except Ramsey trees
I need you to step up
stop panicking you're right there's
something difficult here I know bring
the team together
you got it we're at this line have the
balls to do it mistakes are gonna happen
it all depends on how you handle the
mistake John April 10 did they get older
appetizers yes they did Alex did you
bring this to 19 right and olives in a
culinary table 19. I gotta keep it
together get my head on straight have
confidence in myself and stick to the
game plan right now listen I need one
part daily one Cod one hour check day
and then we'll worry about everything
else but that I mean now yes sir come on
keep it going we've got to drive the
team yes how are we doing on 18. are you
coming right now okay gotta talk to each
other guys okay I want to stay in the
window together good right here right
here thank you sir table six with Chef
Ramsay's encouragement Michael has
rallied back okay lasagna lasagna
lasagna well lasagna in the window baby
beautiful baby food is flowing into the
dining room again at a steady Pace
[Music]
no snacks it tastes great and no
complaints delicious what did you like
about the pizza
how is everybody out there they're
loving it everybody's loving it they're
loving it yeah gotcha you give me a
chicken parm with no home is your shrimp
coming with it it's incredible having
Michael finally step up he's doing a
good job he actually sounds like a boss
today that's a first you guys are doing
a great job cool looks absolutely
gorgeous okay thank you thank you
Michael is now working together with us
hey guys come on baby one more and the
finish line is here they're supposed to
fit like that we're looking for that for
a long time
how'd everything go okay oh my God
excellent yeah we're back on the map
[Music]
okay how you feeling good yes yes
feedback they love the food the old
customers right Mama Rose I thought
you're going to bed huh are you happy
yeah I'm very happy look after your son
I will let him spoil you now
you need to sit and relax and go around
the corner of a little game of bingo
he's good enough to take over yeah it is
I was about to see my account being a
boss hopefully things work out and be
better I'd like a little word with you
yes sir okay
three
important words that right now I need
you to remember stay
the course
if you don't do that we're coming off
track and we're going to slip back day
by day to our old ways
stay the course stay the course Chef I
can't hear you stay the course take a
big deep breath and Shout at me Chef in
my restaurant I'm gonna stay the course
good
well done thank you sir good night thank
you this was just a phenomenal
experience and the thing that changed me
the most is Chef Ramsay that's a God's
honest truth
stay the course you'll get it brother
good night good night he believed in me
and he said I can do it I truly believe
I can do it
[Music]
you proud of me yeah thank you very much
okay okay
you're in good hands
I love you
wow when I first arrived I saw a lazy
owner sat in his Pizzeria watching TV we
made a lot of changes not just to the
restaurants but to the owner Michael
found his voice and finally he's now
speaking not just for himself but for
his mother
wow that baby
[ __ ] ugly
[Music]
only days after Chef Ramsay left
Alexandria silverware wraps over Michael
took his advice to heart and stayed the
course here's your bill chop Tara go get
it baby
oh [ __ ] guys if he needs help jump in
Franco helped him Leone's is once again
a popular spot in Montclair Things Are
as for Rose she can finally rest easy
knowing that her son is in control and
the future of Leoni's looks
brightly Because of You Michael's the
boss and Leon is the hottest restaurant
down you are a lot like Jeff wins
[Music]